[Music]
[Music]
i
absolutely love mountains ironically i
live in what's perhaps the flattest
country on god's green earth
i guess we crave what we don't have one
of my biggest passions in life is hiking
and exploring the rich landscapes the
planet has to offer
for me nothing beats sitting at a
campfire on a remote mountaintop
and gazing up at the stars after a long
day of intense walking and climbing
only to wake up the next day to find
your tent being ravaged by a group of
angry german cows
i try to plan at least one or two hiking
trips abroad annually
if it fits my work schedule and budget
and depending on the mercy of the dutch
weather god of
guess what it just might not rain today
i try to go on as many small day hikes
as i can right here at home
but in the meantime i have to stay
patient and wait for the next big trip
luckily in the meantime we have this
thing called video games which let you
live out your own fantasies and
adventures from the comfort of your own
home
now despite growing up in the early 90s
i never actually
experienced the zelda game up until
ocarina of time i vaguely remember
seeing one of my neighbors kids playing
a link to the past and thinking
this looks neat but i never played it
until way later
ocarina of time is the game that sparked
my love for the franchise and well
looking at the sales numbers i'm
guessing i wasn't the only one
as a kid i didn't exactly get hyped for
games they would simply magically appear
on my path
either from word of mouth making a
random pick at the video store or
playing it at a friend's house
you would think that when majira's mask
was announced the sequel to one of my
favorite games i would know about it as
soon as the word hit the streets but
actually no after i finished the game i
would simply set it aside
or replay it 30 more times and then go
out and play in the woods with my master
stick to slay imaginary monsters
i didn't follow any gaming news barely
read any magazines and the internet was
well
so by the time majira's mask released
instead of grabbing a sleeping bag and
camping in front of the store to get my
copy of the game at launch
my experience went a little more like
hey what do you got there
oh this it's a new zelda game remember
ocarina of time i think this is like the
sequel to it or something
oh cool let's play it i didn't even own
majira's mask on the n64 myself and
i don't think i ever did i would simply
go over to my cousin's house daily to
play it with him and after finishing it
together i borrowed it a couple of times
after and it grew out to become one of
my favorite games
it wasn't until my teenage years when i
first started getting hyped for games
long before they released
the first games to do so were mario
sunshine and the wind waker to a point
where i was constantly buying magazines
downloading trailer and gameplay footage
and at that age even waiting for half a
year for a game to finally drop felt
like an eternity
and then of course we had the twilight
princess reveal
need i say more so what does all this
nostalgic rambling have to do with
breath the wild
well up until my early to mid 20s i
enjoyed many different games and even
branched out to other platforms
i played games like half-life fallout
counter-strike silent hill
among many others but then something
happened it was like hitting a brick
wall
all of a sudden i stopped enjoying video
games
this was horrible timing for me as
skyward sword just came out
and trust me when i say i tried i really
really tried but i just couldn't get
through it
to this day i have never played past the
third dungeon myself
of course nowadays getting wrapped up in
zelda theories and editing videos i had
to do research and learn about the story
and lore found in the game
now this is by no means meant to be a
bash on skyward sword
i know there's plenty of people who
thoroughly enjoyed this game this
is purely a personal thing skyward sword
to me
represents the time when i started to
realize my enjoyment of video
games was starting to fade and this
wasn't unique to this game either
around this time i sold most of my games
and consoles something i regretted this
day by the way
and i rarely played any video games from
that point on i started focusing on
other stuff like
work and other hobbies as i couldn't
exactly force myself to like something i
clearly lost interest in
this state of mind persevered for a few
years and then 2014 came along
now obviously i didn't immediately go
back to being a full-blown gamer right
away but there was this tiny little
spark that ignited within me
and then it stayed mostly quiet for two
years but secretly i kept peeking into
breath the wild news now and again
i discovered the footage of the 2015
game awards presentation with anuma and
miyamoto and then of course we finally
got the first proper trailer in 2016
and with that that little spark grew
into a blaze that almost burned my
apartment down
as soon as i saw those gorgeous
landscapes climbing mechanics
cooking and general theme of survival
and non-linearity i knew that this
was gonna be a game changer to pass the
time between the trailer and the release
in 2017 i picked up fallout 4
which was already out for two years but
i never bothered to pick it up
and when breath of the wild finally came
out i did something i hadn't done
in many many years i took two weeks off
of work
closed myself off from society and
allowed myself to be totally immersed
into the world of hyrule
so what do i think of the game overall
does it have any flaws
of course it does no game is perfect and
it doesn't have to be
ocarina of time had flaws and to this
day it's regarded as one of the finest
achievements in gaming
as a matter of fact milestones usually
are flawed because they dive into
unknown territory
see when i play a game i don't play it
through the eyes of a critic
i can very easily shut that part of my
brain off and simply enjoy what is laid
out in front of me
instead of thinking wow my sword broke
already
man weapons are way too brittle this was
a poor decision made by nintendo
i just adapt to it and think to myself
okay weapons don't last very long
i'd better make sure to always have a
decent stock of different weapons on me
and just move on with my adventure
the part where i start analyzing the
game and picking apart its flaws and
shortcomings doesn't come until way
after i already completed the game
actually i would probably be the worst
critic in the world in that regard
if my job was to form an opinion write
an article and give a game a rating
right upon release
my reviews would mostly consist of very
generous scores
as you can probably deduce from my
channel one of my favorite things in the
zelda series are the dungeons
but instead of thinking the game is good
but it would have been much better if it
had
actual dungeons like the previous games
my reasoning would be
the game is amazing despite the fact
that it doesn't feature any real
dungeons
i could list the things i like or don't
like right here but this isn't meant to
be a review
no matter the flaws i can find and pick
apart about breath the wild
it doesn't take away that which i enjoy
most about the game
the fact that everyone has their own
unique adventure with it
it goes back to the old philosophy of
the first game on nes
where miyamoto wanted to incentivize
gamers to exchange
information tell their own stories of
things they've experienced and
discovered
and share strategies between each other
and now with the technological prowess
that is the internet this is easier than
ever
it is exactly what the series needed
the monumental success of ocarina of
time was both a blessing
and a curse for the franchise on one
hand it launched the series even further
into stardom
on the other it forced nintendo to stick
to a strict formula
now i don't want to step on any toes
here i have a huge soft spot for the
wind waker and i absolutely love
twilight princess
but can you really blame me when i say
that when you take a step
back and take a look at the full picture
most games released after ocarina of
time stayed in that little
comfort zone that ocarina of time
created and i can't blame nintendo for
it
the big exception amongst the 3d titles
released after ocarina of time was
majora's mask sure over the years it's
gained a much bigger appreciation and
went from a cult classic to a fan
favorite
nowadays it's no longer controversial to
say that majora's mask is your favorite
game
but trust me when i say that when it
first released there were a lot of
people who didn't like it
it was weird and confusing uncomfortable
and
what is happening this is reflected back
onto the sales numbers
you would think that a direct sequel to
one of the most popular and praised
games of all time would sell just as
well
if not better but this wasn't exactly
terminator 2 to the original
not even selling half as many copies as
its predecessor
this was a game that tried something
very different and initially it felt
like a slap in the face for a lot of the
fans of ocarina
people in general don't take change very
well unless it's given in small
increments
it's why politics is such a slow process
when a politician gets into office under
the name of
change we're not exactly expecting to
wake up the next day and everyone is
riding pandas to work
on the flip side as with anything else
in life if you repeat it again
and again too often it inevitably gets
stale by the time skyward sword came
along sales numbers had dwindled
significantly
you cannot just slap motion controls on
a game and expect it to feel like
something completely new
you are still doing the same stuff
except instead of pressing a button
you now have to flail your arms around
and again skyward sword isn't to blame
for this
it was the inevitable result of reusing
the same formula over and over again
and only adding small changes as not to
alienate the fanbase too much
every game following ocarina of time and
majora's mask still presented new ideas
but the core of the formula largely
stayed the same breath of the wild was
the game to finally break the mold and
change what we think a zelda game should
be
the series as a whole spans back so far
and it's well on its way to its fourth
decade just think about that for a
moment five years from now this
franchise will exist for 40 years
how many games do you know that are
still going strong today after so much
time
how many television shows or movie
franchises that started in the 80s are
still around today and haven't
disappeared or degraded in quality
this is a rare phenomenon and the way
nintendo managed to achieve this
is by having that one game that one
milestone that defines a generation
this isn't to say that the games in
between these milestones are bad
on the contrary they're all good and
your favorite game
doesn't have to be a milestone as i
stated before milestones are rarely
perfect
because they take bold new leaps into
unknown territory
it's much easier to copy something and
do it better than to try something
completely new
and innovative
when people say that breath the wild
isn't a masterpiece i
cannot argue against it in fact it would
be a pointless argument to have
as it's ultimately based on preference
to me personally
breath the wild is a masterpiece not
because its brush strokes are perfect or
its composition flawless
but because it dared to do something new
and executed well
i mean we're still talking about this
game experimenting with it and
discovering new things more than three
years after its release
i'm of the somewhat older generation of
zelda fans and it's so easy to forget
that there are so many young gamers out
there whose experience with the series
started with breath the wild in many
ways this is the ocarina of time of this
new generation
at the same time i've seen many people
my age who grew tired of the series
returning with a newfound enthusiasm
and because the game is so dynamic we
all have our own reasons for liking it
and our own stories to tell about the
adventures we had for those who did not
enjoy breath the wild
i completely understand big changes
means you're gonna draw in a new crowd
but you're also bound to lose some
the legend of zelda breath the wild
speaks to me because it reminds me of my
hiking trips
i know it's a cliche thing to say but
it's true out there
there's no drama no politics no internet
beef
just you and that mountaintop you want
to reach before nightfall
the game also reminded me that as a 32
year old man
i can still get totally immersed in a
fictional world and it single-handedly
reignited my passion for video games
to me this proves that childhood
nostalgia doesn't always have to dictate
your favorite experiences
and you're never too old to get into
something new modern internet culture
has granted levels of hype
never before seen and this devoted fan
base and all these great theorists
keeping up the hype with all these
creative theories and speculations and
storytelling
ensures that this franchise is stronger
than it's ever been
when we finally get new information
about the sequel we will undoubtedly be
in for a wild ride
and i hope you will be there with us
when it happens
[Music]
you